you about the the pandemic situation
it's our understanding
sage the sage group are meeting today i
don't know if you can confirm that for
us
particularly concerned over the indian
variant
how worried should we be at this stage
well obviously some of the scenes that
we've seen uh in india itself are
heartbreaking and that's why
the uk has done uh so much to uh support
our friends in india with
the oxygen supply that they needed
obviously our genome sequencing
capability here in the uk is a
global class and we will be helping
india and indeed all partners
understand these variants better we have
very robust and we have had for some
time now very robust
border control measures whereby people
need to be tested
uh before arriving in the uk and
quarantine when they do
if travel is essential so it's already
here it's already here isn't it we know
that
some of the covered hot spots and
particularly bolton
they think is is very much linked to the
india variant
well uh as i say we've got a world-class
genomic uh
sequencing capability here in the uk uh
we have a huge
number of uh tests and of course we have
an incredibly effective vaccination
program so
um obviously we keep a close eye on all
variants
we want to make sure we're always basing
our decisions on the most
up-to-date scientific data um
but we we we have seen incredibly
positive numbers
um because of our uh vaccine program we
will be keeping a close eye
on all variants to make sure that we
move forward appropriately
and safely i know the scientists are
looking at this
all the time but certainly the european
medicines agency now their position at
the moment
is that they seem to think mrna vaccines
can neutralize
this strain which which seems to be very
very easily spread
but i mean that includes pfizer and
modern but
not astrazeneca not the astrazeneca jab
which works in a different way so
there's there's potential of a lot of
people in the uk being left vulnerable
to this isn't there
well as i say we always make our
decisions based on scientific
evidence we have amazing scientific
capabilities here in the uk um
and all our decisions will be based on
science on evidence
and in conjunction with as i say this
genuinely world-class scientific
community
that we're privileged to have here in
the uk one of the the
the four tests the key test in moving
down the
the road map out of lockdown is is
looking at variants of concern of which
the indian strain is
is definitely one one member of the sage
group telling the telegraph today that
although they think things will go ahead
on monday as expected they've got real
concern that actually
that the sort of total relaxation
towards the end of june
may now not happen well the sage
uh the scientists and scientists on
stage will make their assessments they
will
report that to government and we will
make decisions
based on the data and the evidence that
they provide
the prime minister the health secretary
always been clear
that the easing of restrictions which um
allow us to get back to a normality
will be done at a pace and in a way
which is safe and we will always be
driven by the data